hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of your favorite
podcast
the only one you like you told me
yesterday you watch zero podcast i watch
every podcast so
it's number one in your book that's true
i don't watch podcast do you watch us
i don't watch our own podcast back to
you those names sometimes
sometimes i watch certain parts back to
kind of like see
if it hit or miss you know i just like
to see what i look like
like am i fatter in my skin you watch
the whole episode back to see if you're
fat or scared no i only watch like the
first like 20 minutes
yeah if i have a moon face or not i am
very fussy i know we're not talking
about weight or anything but i am very
fat
literally nothing fit me i had this on
today in this because literally nothing
fit me
did you did you i just saw way too much
you didn't see anything did you my
god i saw like oh my under boob and like
oh oh my god there wasn't that's my
belly i think it's on my belly
are you wearing a bra i exactly it's my
belly it was my belly this is a belly a
belly looks like a boob
when you haven't seen a flubby one in a
while anyways
sponsored today bye today we are
sponsored by bright sellers and
honey honey oh and really quickly
this thursday is the last chance to be
handsome squidworth
we are bringing spongebob back the
ultimate teddy fresh collab
uh one last time this is it red alert
red alert april 1st 10 a.m
10 am i speaking and my words making
sense yes april 1st 10 am pst
last chance to be i had some squidworth
this piece and more pieces
squidward
squidworth yeah oh
it's squidward i thought it was
squidward
squidward i mean it's it's my hebrew
spongebob that i listen to
academy i feel like
we're nothing we saying makes sense
we're speaking like different languages
octa dog yeti that's hebrew
it's my hebrew spongebob wait what is
that that squidward yeah we did a tick
tock we do hebrews
i'm saying something in me this is the
most confusing episode
gary is the snail i'm talking to the
steele
oh god okay last chance of
teddy fresh follow teddy fresh on
instagram april 1st 10 am last chance
last chance to be handsome squidward in
hebrew it's
[ __ ] bob
spunk okay
um oh before we get into too much
because there's in my opinion a lot to
talk about
you're just pumped two minutes before
you're like i am so excited about this
well okay so let me tell you what we're
doing today
we have arranged um a whole
how it oddly satisfying there's this
like
it's a trend that existed before tick
tock but on tick tock there's this whole
thing of people like smashing their
hands in the cake
i love it smushing [ __ ] and doing all
this so we are going to be doing
that here today dan cut to this camera
look at this
oh it's not on it's not on don't cut to
the camera yet
but we have our own cameras we're going
to be slapping cakes and slamming
i love it peeling skin some people find
that oddly satisfying
nobody finds out they did i had 6
million everyone's like this is
satisfying
really i should say some skin for us to
peel i have actually i wanted to ask you
about that because it was so
intense on your notes yeah it's in my
notes but we had like a huge passover
family dinner while you were there and
it was fun but before we get into all
that i want to
say because of all of the
vlog squad and david stuff and all the
essay
i or we thought it would be appropriate
to
start a fundraising campaign
for rain which is the leading
um charity organization
for helping victims of
essay and uh abuse and all
such things i think it's great i think
it's fantastic
we already met our goal so there's no
pressure to donate that's what we
so here's what we did a whole thing me
me and trisha each
donated ten thousand except trisha i was
like you [ __ ]
she gave 10 100. i don't know why that's
showing because you said you did that
too it said for fees i wasn't trying to
upstage you although
hindsight i should have actually done
like more but i i said for a fee so
like ten thousand went to the charity
and then like fees were a hundred
dollars when you said you did that but
didn't show up or what
to be honest my accountant donated so i
didn't know she's probably like
she probably was like no fees well
that's why it says that but hey i'm
happy to donate a little more
but anyway we each put 10 000 each and
then
we set the goal of 20 000 because like
trisha said i don't want to be like
expecting but
if you want to help donate if you want
to you know
i like to turn this thing into a
positive here of all these things
happening
so and raising awareness so i'm going to
put this link in the description so if
you guys want to
uh donate frenemies team frenemies
let's go and something funny to note is
that
me and trisha having put 10 000 a piece
in we're already the number one
team and guess who's number two mirror
max and weinstein
yeah yes like i'm sorry weinstein i
think you're asking the pony up a little
bit more
mirror max could pony up a little more
than twenty thousand i'm sorry
what we what is it is that officially
theirs or did someone set it up on
behalf of like
miramax and the weinsteins let's look
i'm hoping
donate yeah it's alumni we incur
employees of miramax dimensions and the
weinstein company
i think they're just like yeah weinstein
you know
people who still work for the company
are like let's also donate so we don't
look horrible
yes um well miramax should probably
harvey weinstein probably should donate
something
i guess that'd be a mission of guilt
though he's like i didn't do anything
wrong
weinstein's like what am i donating he
did anything wrong but you know we here
to help
yeah that's a good he should be yeah
yeah that's a good point
or like quit international well once
again well once he's like
i'm pro essay why would i i'm pro
essay oh weinstein i don't think he's
oh you're just making that up i thought
he said that he's like why would i want
to prevent that i'm for that
people who like worked with him like uma
thurman and quentin tarantino they
should donate maybe
because they made so much money off of
such a good point to our
campaign yeah or the mirror maxwell
no no no no don't do it in weinstein's
name do it in our name
so who are we calling out quentin
tarantino
uma thurman those are two quentin
especially was to work so close
ben affleck and matt damon goodwill
hunting
let's pony up friend me's we should do a
woody allen one two it's like mirror
sovina and all those people that could
like
you know donate woody allen diane keaton
definitely would not because she still
stands by him so
i'm still so mad about it even though i
know that the woody allen's yeah it
makes me
feel bad and the sickest [ __ ] i came out
of that so angry
i will never ever watch woody allen
i'm gonna be honest woody allen's
overrated it's like oh neurotic jew it's
like that's the last thing i need in my
life is another erotic jew out there
representing me i mean i loved it
because of someone who didn't know any
jews
i thought it was so cool that's when i
first fell in love with jewish people
because i thought that was so cool they
had all these little ticks like i have
and i was like oh maybe i'm a jew
don't say i fell in love with jewish
people
you couldn't say that about any other
ethnic group but i thought you're not
saying i thought you're a culture say
this i that's when i
fell in love with black people right
right right okay
you avoid sound right okay i'll just say
that's when i
liked woody allen okay okay you're
probably right about that i am right i'm
trying to be more pc for sure
okay good i am i probably love that we
love pc people there there's a string of
tic-tacs that think i'm like racist and
i reach out to those people and i'm like
let me know
what what i'm doing that comes across
that way because i need to stop and i
need to like be the opposite because
that's not mean if i'm coming across
that way in any way i don't want to be
that way oh really
so i'm trying i reached out to a couple
creators and what did they tell you um
one was just like that i don't speak out
enough and i agree with that i think my
issue was okay for instance
addison ray was on jimmy fallon and she
did a bunch of these dances and like
three-fourths
pull that up because that [ __ ] was funny
and weird but the thing is
i never spoke up oh they're gonna claim
us huh
uh tonight's show yeah for sure no they
did they did uh copyr like copy
they didn't do the right music like they
did that you know copyright free right
now but the
the show itself is gonna get the light
show itself yeah i'm sorry oh my gosh
just kick shredder sorry
no i literally didn't see him he's just
right there um no but the reason i never
like stuck like said enough i guess like
even during black lives matter i try to
say what i can i just never wanted to
come across like in sincere what are you
supposed to
you're supposed to call addison write
dancing on the light show what is that
no well i think when i've had opinions
about something i've been scared to talk
about what did you do wrong
i think that there's a little bit and i
agree actually with this so when i when
i agree with something i should like say
it more i just never want to be like the
white knight in every situation where
i'm just not no pun intended on the
white just like i don't want to be the
person that always is like like anthony
padilla just has to stick up for you
know everybody
however you don't need to say no pun
intended on the white knight
well cause i don't mean like i'm a
caucasian knight i know i i meant like
it's a well it's a well-known uh well i
don't want people to think that i'm like
oh i'm this okay
well um i don't know anyways i'm sorry i
don't want that to come across and
sincere either
i talk to people like it just help if
you're more vocal and i agree because
there are certain things that i am
i do feel like strongly about with the
addison right thing and i didn't say
anything because i was like oh it's not
really my way
what was the problem with edison ray so
don't understand so she
did which by the way killed her
performance i'm obsessed i actually
really like her new song obsessed i
think she's really good
her like dancing queer everything was
great she did a segment prior to that
where jimmy fallon was like holding up
signs of like popular dances like
corvette corvette you know like those
kind of dances
and she was supposed to do them they did
the same thing with charlie about a year
ago charlie also did these dances
um and they ended up giving credit to
the creators in
the description i think after some
uproar about it but if three-fourths of
these dances are by
like black tick talkers black creators
like they should be the ones that get to
perform this on these shows and why is
charlie now add us in the one schedule
because quarterback corvette was you
know fly boy like kiki like
and i and i i'm only sticking up for
this because i do think that's a really
integral part like the people who come
up with dances like a lot of them are
black renegade
who are the three girls performing dixie
charlie and addison and like that's just
it was just it's just [ __ ] to the
person who came up with that answer to
your point yeah that feels a little bit
of a slight thought more about it i
should have done i'm so scared
i don't think i think you're right in
that you don't need to champion every
single cause no but this one i feel
strongly about because i'm like yeah
it would be nice to show the people who
created the dances and at the same time
you do make 100 tick tocks a day so
there's space
in your schedule for it too well and i
thought you know i always i always
critique david for not talking like
doing
apologizing on twitter not giving his
biggest platforms but since i think
front of me is my biggest platform i was
like
uh we should address this that there is
a little who are we giving a shout out
do we need to
credit the original do you know who they
are yeah well i just know at the top we
had i know fly boy
i know fly boy shout out let me get the
all of them
well they're in the description but
there's oh kiki shout out
i follow i follow that we'll link them
in the description the
maya nicole
why are they private well they are they
they're not though but why would he make
it
private maybe to get more people follow
i don't know really
anyway i just you know what we're gonna
do
we're gonna link these guys in the
description it's not gonna be at the top
you're gonna have to expand but it's
gonna be it should be more than that
though like jimmy fallon linked them and
i'm like jimmy fallon you should have
they're big creators can i do it what
more can i do i mean you guys can come
dance on our show
not that way you want people
it's just it's just disheartening yeah
and honestly i'm not gonna lie like
this is no hate to add a center it's
like they don't do the dances justice
really like the creators who started
these dances like
kill it like and and you can tell when
addison's doing it she's writing
corvette correct like the audience like
doesn't know what to say they're like
it's that bit doesn't belong in that
because like the late shows were like
all that farts who are watching tv like
you have to be like over
let's say probably over 65 to enjoy
jimmy fallon right so you've got these
young girls doing these
corvette corvette it's like what okay
yeah i i just i just never want to come
across as insincere i think that's why i
like even during like walking around i
try to say what i can but i just i never
want to come across like
i'm doing it i don't know what do they
call those like performance activists
i'm not that person but i do like this
one i
felt really strongly about like you know
what i should say something because i
just you know
sometimes staying silent is a little bit
like being complicit so you're right
they say
they say uh there's a saying like that
that
i can't recall that i can't recall a
really good one right
dan help me out what is it oh oh oh oh i
got it
i got it evil uh
when oh i got it when
when the goodman stand evil wins
when the good men stand by and say
nothing
google it it's not but do you see what
i'm saying
right that's not the saying it's
obviously way more wealthy i've never
heard that one
it's great it was about the holocaust oh
go ahead dan what is it yep
you found it that's the only thing
necessary oh my god these pop-ups
the only thing necessary for triumph of
evil is for good men to do nothing
now that's a quote okay do we love that
we love it thank you are we that's are
we good people in this
yeah okay you're we're triumphing over
evil speaking of jews passover yesterday
with your family
fun so much fun honestly so much fun and
agenda wait what what hold on uh we have
something we want to present to you
i love surprises is this a good one or a
bad one
you tell me is it scary ian bring out
the surprise
this is a little something to
commemorate our 1.5 year anniversary of
meeting
wait for it oh oh my gosh
okay i thought it was gonna be a picture
of us but this is um oh my gosh
wait show it oh my god oh oh oh jesus
christ
no it's censored right it's censored
enough well they'll tell us oh my gosh
this isn't me you were printed up in the
new yorker
the culture page we wanted to
commemorate your achievement
of being an icon and one here of you
stuffing your face with a burger
i don't know why put that it's awesome
yes and the contents oh
that's so nice i would give you a hug
but we don't really hug don't hug me i
want to but like
this is amazing i'm gonna put this in my
office thank you guys
and of course it's bedazzled and
everything the frame you're like david
dobrik minus the essay you always are
surprising me
because he used to get people like
teslas oh like with giving me gifts he
would surprise you by like
like gave me hamilton tickets and i was
like ah oh he would do nice
oh he would do nice things minus the
then after traumatized because i feel
like what
the david the david dobrik surprises
were more like payoffs
i mean for the record jason bought the
tickets not david but it was for david's
vlog so i guess never surprised me with
anything but
they did that after like trying you guys
went to puerto rico to see
yeah he paid ten thousand dollars a
ticket it was for a fundraiser like you
go to puerto rico today
because because he's from puerto rico
well at the time there was like
hurricane so they were
like hurricane relief and so that's a
nice thing yeah but jason bought it but
he let david have the bit for his vlog
and he sent 20
anyways i guess anyways all i'm saying
is like you're like david dobrik
surprising me with gifts like here's a
tesla and i'm like ah
cause you did the peeps you did this yes
i feel like you've done some money i
can't even keep up
well what can i say we have we we we pay
attention here on the show
no there's other good ones i forget so
anyway it was this was something
i thought it was that picture i was so
excited because this one this also well
we can do that too
where is this at where is this okay so
we were cleaning out our old office
which literally i don't even know why
we've been paying rent on it and we
haven't even been in there in a year
so we're like why are we paying because
we bought you guys know we bought a new
warehouse that we're going to build our
set
and and everything we're just waiting
we've been waiting because of coven for
the plans to get approved for like six
months so it's like just sitting there
it's so annoying
but anyway we have this office that
we've been paying rent on for like a
year that's been totally empty so
we were like why are we doing that so we
cleared out this office
it's gone it's done yeah it's done and
we're moving all of the stuff into the
new place
but we found we looked this was the
first time we met one like one and a
half years ago
so skinny we were oh my god i kind of
feel like
yeah i think i must have gained 50
pounds still
why are we so skinny i guess quarantine
but it is quarantined it's been a long
year and a half
i mean yeah i was really depressed and
miserable when i was there so
you know honestly you were happy way i
guess well you know what
it's just it's just crazy how
life comes at you fast yeah yours was
really sweet that was so unlike you i
was like
i was so nice but it felt like something
i would like i think about but it was
just
yeah because it just it was just like
wow you know
just i mean like this is something with
some unexpected [ __ ]
i agree and that's why i try and make
amends with people that i have like beef
with like i try to do another podcast
with someone i had beef with and i think
this could be a beautiful friendship
with ours oh hannah yeah gabby is
thinking like maybe this will be like
you know uh
it's good you try and then i was like no
massive failure but really
but sometimes you get a friendship you
get a fiance
you get a family you know your whole
family has partnered basically you're
basically you owe me everything
a kind of yeah kind kind of no and also
you're the only one like once you start
talking about david also i was like
everyone listen
ethan is talking about david as opposed
to me talking about david for two years
about the same stuff it's not anything
groundbreaking i was talking about those
girls two years ago i was talking about
this
and no one really cared so at least i'm
not saying in a bad way i was like at
least
i guess people listen
i agree maybe i i maybe it is misogynist
i mean for sure when i mean i think
i think it i think people are just they
discredit you too easily
or the whole vlog squad just was on this
crazy discredit campaign of you know
well and i get it that's why that's when
you did and you did drive your car
high on me but no one knew that that
wasn't like a public thing that was
three months after that
no it wasn't like i made that because
once you drop i'm just with peace and
love once you drive your car high on
meth in someone's house it's hard to
take them seriously yeah but that was
three months after my first mental
health that was mental
hospitality that was like anyways i get
it and that's another reason why i try
not to like
put myself into situations because a lot
of times people don't want trisha paytas
defending them they're like oh trish is
trash please don't defend me
you know what i mean so i try not to
white knight people
if they don't want me to i just no pun
intended i mean that one i think is okay
cause i'm talking about general oh yeah
anyways
so anyway what i wrote was this photo
was taken 1.5 years ago the first time i
met trisha paytas in our studio
which by the way we had a great that
what the one thing i always say about
you is like
i think you were on the show twice
before we made the podcast together
and each time was like a really good
episode
yeah three times it was the one right
before quarantine remember like two days
before quarantine
right we did the episode too right where
we saw the bachelor's i was like oh you
guys are sabotaging me oh yeah the
bachelor i forgot
so we did like two times and then the
bachelor but like every time we had you
on it was like so good mm-hmm yeah
entertaining you were so
you're just such an entertaining like
great guest
and i feel like i feel like we have
i always felt like we had a good
chemistry i think probably because we're
both like just very
forthcoming and unfiltered in a way i
was like i don't think that's why we
connected
i was like not even close to saying that
but i was like he wants to say
well they said i'm not well we are both
fat
no we are skinny legends here i was 180
there i remember i was on tour i was
like skinny look
you know why we look so happy because we
were skinny and that was also before the
interview we took it before i remember
oh before tragedy it was a little
friction
but anyway um i said there was no
freaking oh okay yeah a little
i was i think i was like yeah oh here's
a really mean comment i should read that
oh with it the top one
yeah but anyway yeah people say you're
friends with me they say since then she
has become my sister-in-law
soon to be my partner in crime and one
of my best friends
life is one strange mother lover you're
my only best friend right now so
i'm one of yours you're my only we pound
it we don't hug
i it makes me sad though because you
hugged moses the other day and was the
first time i saw that and i was like
well because we don't want pelvis we've
never hugged not even before covered
we've already
i tried to hug you once you're like
don't touch me because that was so
insane
because we've never had that you don't
need the heart so then you were like no
but i feel i had ila for the first time
last night
it was amazing wait we hugged me and
elog oh nice
and like she just gives really good hugs
actually like you wouldn't think so
what i love being i love them people i'm
going to say i'm not shaming but you
think she's a skinny so you want to
think such good bugs but like
she went underneath and like brought in
it was a really good hug i was like wow
i was really like can i say something
yeah
there are i feel like there's two types
of people in the world
people who analyze the hugs they receive
and the people who are fully unaware
i don't i never think about the quality
of a hub i always think about it like i
feel like
if we were to hug you'd give me a side
hug like you know how you just put like
one arm around like a weird side
yeah i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
go chest to chest but that makes it
uncomfortable for me because i'm not
thinking somebody wants to touch my
chest like my dad doesn't do that either
he'll do like this weird like side thing
and i'm like
you can well well regardless i don't
think about dan do you think about
quality of hugs
um yeah i guess i do yeah really
meeting someone yeah i'm a hug quality
analyzer moses you think about how
quality maybe it's just me
yeah i try to avoid hugs all together
what does that mean though
you just hugged ethan you were the one
he said as we were leaving he's like
let's just go he's like i'll say bye
ethan like we'll see by him from across
the counter he's like no i'm gonna go
give him a hug so you were the one that
initiated the hug with ethan
right but that's after kovi they got
vaccines people feel more comfortable
yeah but why are you avoiding hugs
because
a lot of times the other person's like
perfume or stuff stays on you oh you
hold that
thing water is pure water has no smell
but anyway yeah i try to avoid it i just
like hugging
and then ian and sam i'm just trying to
see if i'm the only freak here are you
guys do you guys analyze hug quality
no no okay good sam
okay but see
okay she said she said sam ian's
girlfriend
who's here so she some people give
really cozy hugs
yeah so i guess half the room it's split
it's like you know it's very interesting
how
some things are never spoken about like
i find this very much to be like
some people wipe their ass from the
front and some from the back and then
the
others don't know that even the whole
the other team exists at all
so hogging quality is like that yeah the
wiping thing is like i don't get it i
actually wipe i don't even want to say
it i actually wipe back to friend
that's how i white but you're not
supposed to because you because i don't
have a vagina i mean i don't get
infections why would you unless you're
like like how sloppy do you have to be
i'm not like having it half out and like
wiping it out i don't know it's like
yeah it's like okay if you can't handle
your [ __ ]
um yeah but people act like i'm getting
like a peace and love i'm sorry this is
gross but
i wipe back to front too and people are
like act like i've got [ __ ] all over my
balls that's so much
what are you talking about i don't know
why i thought you were a bidet i thought
you were team bidet well i
i went uh there was a day when i
before i ascended to the to the greats
the great throne that i'm on now i used
to wipe
did you yeah there you go you've
elevated i thought yeah your mom gave a
double hug to me and moses she kind of
went with both arms around us it was
really interesting because i was ready
to go for like a full hug around her and
she went with her other arm around moses
and me i was like
so rate the hugs you got yesterday
yeah um i would no that's like
that's like no okay no don't okay i
think moses mom goes really good hug
she's always hugged yeah
yes your mom did too your mom was very
lively yesterday
i loved her i loved your family like i
didn't feel really bad i was like wow i
was like i don't know if i was just
i don't know what it was should i read
this mean comment or do we not want bad
guys
because sometimes i like me comments
what is it what you see
oh my god what is it bad i can't even
read it let's see what okay i'm read i'm
reading this mean comment because
oh oh yeah this one's me here let me
read it before i show up
well i'm just not gonna show it because
i don't want to send a mob of people
after this person
that's a good idea yeah this one's bad
let's not read it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
on the note when people do give like
hate comments like that it's like i've
been fighting i don't read
i mean i'm glad you guys have given me
multiple chances though one blow i
remember you text me right after it was
really bad and i remember being like oh
my god why is he texting me because i
thought we would never talk again like
that last one of the last plots we had
and i was like oh i really messed it up
this time and then you're like i hope
you're okay and i was like oh my god
like i was so i
that was like so anyways oh yeah yeah
you guys give multiple chances you guys
are forgiving people and honestly like
it's good because like
it's not like you killed my dog or
anything we just had a little bit of a
fight
yeah don't kill my dog then we'll have a
problem yeah i won't i haven't had um
i've had an episode in a while which is
crazy which is scary yesterday i had a
thought in my head to like sabotage
everything for a minute not in here not
here but like before i came i was like
i'm going to sabotage everything
sometimes i get those moves
it's just an intrusive thought probably
yeah it's so weird
if you have like a conscious thought of
like oh i'm going to do it that's just
an intrusive thought
um yeah anyways
so anyway passover with the family was
amazing i also wanted per se that
passover at the family we had a lot of
photos and stuff there was a lot of
like we're all vaccinated now yes
the major i would say um
every like almost everyone there is
vaccinated yeah and it was because they
were in different states or no
or just because you had the hookup
because you know you like you said the
person that works for you guys knows how
to get the hook up the back
it's not a hookup we're in well my
parents and all the old people got are
fully vaccinated
my br my brother-in-law is a teacher my
brother is a teacher
i'm fat you sent me a tick tock being
like here's an obese person getting on
yeah
that was so funny i was so confused you
said that i like i was like
i didn't wasn't sending it to call you
fat i just thought it was funny you
literally
it was like someone's like you can get
the vaccination because you're you know
let me pull it up i was like and then
that was it that was
our conversation i was just trying to i
was just trying to share a funny tick
tock with you like god forbid
okay i sent you this just because it was
funny i wasn't trying to call you fat
why else would someone send this to you
why else would you send this anyway
because like you share
something funny with a friend did you
share this with anybody in your family
i shared it in the chat with me that
person you know you sent this to me
okay all right well here let's watch it
have you have you signed up to get
vaccinated yet i have to do it under
that link
that you sent me well we had one for a
thousand oaks but
or whatever but we had one for well did
you send your information to lino no we
haven't done that yet
well what the hell she'll sign up for
you just send her your info and also
your fat so you qualify i'm kidding
i'm just kidding because of the argument
i'm sorry look who's talking i'm [ __ ]
mad you're no you're not but the haircut
doesn't do you any favors
well i know trust me why don't you wear
a beanie until it grows for a little bit
because i don't care you think i look
fat with no hair
i don't think it's that sweet you call
me fat so i'm just trying to reiterate
yeah we're about left we're we're both
fat i have one
ourselves to see who's fatter because i
feel like that would give me some peace
of mind
well to be totally fair in this
conversation i
am like six to seven inches taller than
him
so like you know what i mean yeah but
you do have the massive
that's true mine are like 30 pounds you
could weigh them on a
little grocery store look we're we don't
need to
we don't it's not a contest trisha we
both should be not a contest it's for
peace of mind to be like okay if we're
equally fat we can jab at each other
we're equally
fat i don't know you well who do you
think's found i don't know i have no
idea
i i frankly think i think i am i think
i'm 230 right now for real i need to
really lose weight because literally
nothing's fitting
i mean not to turn into that but like i
wonder we need like a body
we need to you know what we need to do
is do the body fat index or like what is
it called the weight
fat index it tells you how much of your
body percentage is fat
oh so that's how you really no i don't
wait dan isn't that just based on height
yeah like we could calculate that
ourselves right now body body mass index
my thighs definitely crush yours mine
are
yeah so why are they so big and yours
are so skinny
should we do that right now should you
want to do how do you do it
oh so so maybe we'll do it next week ian
or do you think we're equipped to do it
now well there
i just search for a calculator it looks
great this one just needs
height let's not do it before we eat
have an eating contest next week
we see jillian michael's on here to
train us don't you want to know what's
important
okay let's no but you're right you're
right you are right we have a skill
we have no no no no i changed my mind no
let's do it
okay you don't want to do it we have a
skill right there we should cosplay as
the two fatties from hairspray do you
see that movie
really what can i show you we would look
so good as these characters so can i
talk you need this one and one more time
or you're uncomfortable with this i
think i'm
uncomfortable i think i might actually
like try and un-alive myself if we do
this
really yeah let's not do it oh let me
watch this tick tock first
are you talking about the old hairspray
or the new one um both
wait i want to show the tick tock that
apparently upset you this weekend that i
was sharing because i thought it was
funny okay
this is us is it a picture of divine
that's john travolta
oh it is it's john travolta yeah that's
him and yeah you never saw hairspray
okay
i don't watch i don't know i should what
do you want they lost me at hairspray
oh all you do is play video games
according to your family yesterday they
thought you would want to be nothing
not weaponizing just saying that's what
my mom said my grandpa said once because
i used to want because my family's
annoying and i mean or like
for i just like you saw it like how
they're obsessed with football it's like
it's it's
it's embarrassing yeah like i'm trying
to put theodore to sleep
and my dad's going at the top of his
lungs like he has no
consideration for anything like you're
adopted that's
like 100 like not even i don't see any
similarities
i've always said that but apparently i
do look like my mom don't i
i don't see it i was trying to see like
your dad or your mom and i literally
couldn't see it i was so confused like i
hey
listen i'd be happy to be a doctor i
think i'm adopted too i think my
moroccan is adopted
i've always i've always dreamed of
having been adopted it would explain a
lot
your family's great you're just so
different than all of them i was like
whoa
oh yeah what i was saying was i didn't
want to see it from my family is that
like
because my brother and my sister tried
to make an effort to
connect with my dad through this whole
sports thing which he's like weirdly
obsessed with
and i think that there's the
psychological explanation is that i
didn't want to be
like my dad i didn't want to connect
with my dad oh
and so i took up different hobbies and
i mean with peace and love i like me and
my dad are on good terms and everything
yeah that's like the psychological
explanation oh interesting
your dad was on two game shows though so
he said icon
he told you about that yeah cud
embarrassing no i love it
wait what game shows i asked him he was
a contestant on some stupid game shows
yeah they weren't like any ones i
recognized but
he said he won um some kitchen knives
i'll tell you
i'll tell you he won a pair of kitchen
knot or like silverware set yeah that it
had like wooden handles
and he [ __ ] kept those
like for 30 years he would not throw
them away because he cherished them but
they're starting to rot like as a kid i
remember
we were still using that i remind them
so clearly because it's all he was
allowed us to use
because they're so proud of it yeah but
they're starting to rot it's made of
wood
no no no my mom you know what i got me
thinking is we should do
um we should go on family feud your
family versus my family
because they did a celebrity one with
people i have no idea who they are can
we invite ourselves on that show
yeah we could try to reach out yeah i
would do that i'd be [ __ ] happy that
would be
[ __ ] really good i wonder if it's so
fun i feel like my
dad would be good my sister would be
good
i'm not sure my brother he was like a
calculator yesterday he's like they're
like what's this and celsius he's like
dude
no because he's got like he's got more
of a rain man brain than like a survey
brain
they could come in handy though for them
because they go like what's the
what's the never would what do people
call
have it whoopee that's a newlywed game i
think
oh i see oh but like top 10 names for
having whoopee
no it's like we asked a hundred people
on the street what is something that you
can get i mean dan do you think we could
get on that show
i mean i don't watch it regularly but
wasn't like ninja on that show
no yeah a thousand percent my the guy um
angel my friend angel has my hair he has
you get us in i'm in it really dude it's
not take it off
is it still uh steve harvey that hosts
it
if i don't get one of these looks from
steve harvey i need one of these it is
still steve harvey oh my god you guys
need to interact with steve harvey wait
i made a video like i made a video a
while ago [ __ ] on steve harvey for
being a douche
i love him he's from cleveland i stand
by steve harvey i love him
honestly it'd be iconic my mom was on
wheel fortune like three times
i have i made a whole i went every game
wait hold on steve i for steve harvey
h3h3po i need to revisit this because
we do we're uh we should throw it a
break right oh really
we're a little over having too much fun
over here
all right we'll be right back
bright sellers is the wine service that
helps you find wine you love while
making wine more accessible to everybody
bright cellar is gives you a
personalized test to find the best wine
suited for you and you know what you
have access to wines from italy france
and even right here in california oh my
god
the world at your fingertips south
africa portugal and of course
that's that's all of them plus you can
pretend you're a wine connoisseur
because they give you little facts about
wine so you can feel really smart and
boujee when you're drinking you are
going to be basically a uh
some is it a sommelier i believe you're
going to get one of those cups you they
literally have little cups that they fit
and they spit it out
yeah that's you that's you if you do
that could be you if you stop
playing um you're about to enter a whole
fun new exciting world of wine
and it's gonna be like you've been
drinking wine for years even if you
haven't
right you're gonna get bright sellers
pairings with crazy
their crazy accurate algorithm that is
gets it first you put a microchip in
your brain in an analog and i'm just
kidding
you love doing that that's your joke
it's just funny it's like it's way over
the top
yeah no what's not a joke is it come
straight to your door
wait no yeah you don't there's no
microchip
in the brain needed all you do is take a
30 second
quiz and you let the wine magic happen
and they'll pair you with six
wine bottles that fit your taste profile
i don't like one perfectly
send it back they'll replace one for you
what
yeah they want to please they aim to
please at bright sellers we love that
you know i mean what what better do you
need than to spend a night with your
loved one or your friends or whoever
with the perfect
bottle of wine that's paired just for
your taste you know what i'm saying are
there any discounts for our listeners if
they're friendly
listen to this okay we are giving
listen carefully 50 off your first
six months five zero half 50 percent i'm
sorry what
yeah that's crazy i i heard they're
running out of grapes
with a deal like this oh the grapes
are gonna be gone six bottles for 50
off by going to the link in the bio
brightsellers.com
frenemies that's bright sellers
they're making me spell sellers well
c e l l a r s
dot com you all know how to spell for
sellers
brightsellers.com frenemies you support
the show and you get wine
sellers.com frenemies and you take only
seven question quiz
you get match the perfect wine and you
receive 50 off your first six bottles
come on forget about it
and you get your wine passport get a
wine passport so you could travel to
mars and drink
wine on mars i'm kidding that's a joke
it's so crazy and try
wine from all over the world by heading
to brightsellers.com
frenemies 50 off your first bright
sellers box links in the description
thank you please support the show by
supporting bright sellers
i was going to start this oh go ahead
shout out to our sponsor of the show
honey
a proud sponsor to sponsor that i use
all the time without even having to
think about it it's free to download
easy steps you save money forget about
using honey you're doing a disservice to
yourself and your wallet
wow and we all shop online like come on
who's going through the stores these
days are you kidding me
you're going to the store you don't have
to clip coupons the coupons are online
just waiting for you to
be harvested by honey this unthinking
machine of saving it saves and it saves
and you can never stop
it it's honey okay
too much listen honey is this is what
honey does
when you go to check out at one of your
favorite stores and trust me one of your
favorite stores are on honey that's over
30
000 stores online ranging from tech
gaming fashion
food delivery so when you go to check
out honey
searches the whole internet
automatically
for the best coupon code that's gonna
save you the most
money boom it's free it takes
two clicks you open it at the browser
extension
you click it it installs immediately
there's no catch
it's really it's nothing more than just
magic
money saving life set it and forget it
the crock pot of the internet
oh couldn't have said it better imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites put yourself there just
meditating sephora you're checking out
the honey button drops down
all you have to do is click apply coupon
are you there
yeah for sure okay you wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
uh it found one for that site you
imagining this
honey found the coupon and now
the price has dropped wow it's that
simple wow honey is god
yeah join honey.com frenemies if you
want to download and support the show
which you should be doing anyways with
honey but hey why not supporters
so this this is the part i have to read
if you don't already have funny
you're straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally
free and installs in a few seconds and
by getting it you're gonna be doing
yourself a solid
and supporting this podcast thank you
very much
i'd never recommend something i don't
use they make me say that which is a
little odd but it's true i
genuinely use honey yeah bible i
genuinely do
oh it's on all my browsers hand to god
hand to god
from my mouth to god's [ __ ] he's
listening i know he is
god's like that one's true that one is
true get honey for free at
jointhoney.com
frenemies that's join honey.com
frenemies should we harmonize it
join are you high or low i'll go i'm
i'm hot i'm low i'll go high
[Music]
so if we do family feud i want one of
these looks from steve harvey
you'll definitely get those i love when
we have like outside people in here
that's this whole bit yeah but it's
funny at least it doesn't like kiss you
on the mouth remember
that's good that was a pretty good
impression that's what he does
when someone gives a dumb answer all he
does is he puts the fl he goes
that's all he does i like it it's funny
probably your future is hosting family
feud
[ __ ] kill me for sure i could see you
doing that no i'm retiring no you'll
host like a thousand dollar pyramid like
one of those things you know
that's you and then and then you know
what else i can see is is ethan for sure
hosting like a pageant of some kind and
announcing the wrong
winner like he did no you think i'll f
oh the wrong miss universe
you remember that of course they don't
like and i'm saying this as someone
who's also your weight they don't like
heavy people hosting those kind of
things they like to have slim even if
slim does not look like
well hold on we have some fat hoes drew
carey lost weight before he hosted it
right they're like dude we're gonna need
you to lose some weight
everybody even jimmy kimmel lost weight
like before he looks like they're like
listen
in general people don't like fat people
isn't that crazy that's really great but
no
that's like one hatred i mean there's so
many hatreds i don't get i don't want to
say that's the one hatred i don't get
but it's like
why do people hate people that are fat
because they're not because they think
they're lazy
and have no self-control so how would
that affect anyone it's not like i look
at someone that's
like broke and i'm like oh my god you're
so dramatic it doesn't affect me like no
i'm not saying it's true i'm just saying
i see that
conveyed all the time i've probably even
said stuff like that in the past you
think they're like lazy
i don't know i just think it's like it's
such a but there's this whole thing
i hear people even people i really like
that i listen to all the time like
howard stern it always goes on and on
about ow just
put down the fork fatty you know what i
mean oh well i hate that
that's like so like because it's a
psychological thing like honestly if i
could be 100 pounds i would but
obviously there's something
like yeah hello i'd love to be a skinny
legend can i watch this [ __ ] tick
tock please
all right here it is i'm not an
essential worker
um hmm okay how do i say this
um the what does this mean what is that
what is that well it's um
there's a certain thing okay if you hit
it
you can you can get you can get it um
[Music]
has to do with um um
all right well when you figure it out
you let me know i want that vaccine okay
yeah did you hear that by may first we
should all be eligible for the
background believe me though i mean
i'm down i can go get it i need to go
get a head pre-existing edition
literally all you have to do okay i will
i will do it did you
send me in the bro of course i did moses
you have it so you're responsible for
this [ __ ]
could be not the first person to be
responsible i'll be more responsible
with this well because
so entertainment is considered essential
essential service and fat i'm going to
die soon fat is like
oh honestly i hate when people say that
it's like oh like eating fast food take
10 years off your life
i'm more than happy to have 10 years off
that's an easy exchange
i have a belly full of nuggets when i
die i'm really happy bury me
with the belly full of nuggets seriously
you know that's funny
that's good maybe because i like love
food but honestly like i don't
understand people like
like they say jennifer anderson hasn't
had like any carbs or cheeses for like
10 years okay oh [ __ ] die
sad because that's what i'm saying die
sad cardboard the quality of life
hey now honestly it gets me angry that
she doesn't eat pizza
that's crazy to me that's crazy to me
that people like don't eat pizza but
it's like yeah what like oh people who
are so fit
like that are like you know you see them
on instagram and tick tock and they're
like
it's like okay yeah they look good but
you know they suffer
but you know some people don't enjoy
eating i don't think there's certain
people that lila doesn't like eating
right so amazing i wish that was me but
i think it's just because we like love
eating just like some people love
spending or doing drugs or whatever it
is like
i will yeah i kind of wish i didn't love
eating so much so yeah that would like
make my life
so less complicated oh i know like if
you didn't enjoy it you just did it
because you had to eat that would be
amazing
but that's a that's a but honestly i was
thinking about this right like some of
these people write like the david
dobrik's of the world and stuff like
that i'm like
why are they so stupid why do they do
this stuff like humiliate people
like that's what they get off on if
getting up on
last week we're having a whole
conversation about like what is his
sexuality
yeah we're like is he gay he doesn't
seem interested in
sex at all yeah did you tell me that he
was like a [ __ ]
no okay so somebody sent me a link and i
watched it
from the podcast maybe maybe ian you can
find it real fast i don't remember where
it was
i don't want to kink shame him i don't
think there's anything wrong with this
at all but i thought it was just
interesting because it's just to analyze
his character
right if you if you're into like
cuckhold or whatever it is
i'm not saying i'm not shaming you at
all i mean god bless you know
what was he doing let that bull ride
your wife to [ __ ] all the way to
valhalla and back
he loves it so he said they were having
a conversation on the podcast and i'm
and i'm comfortable saying this because
i listen to it with my own ears
he says that he would love to watch his
significant other
have sex with somebody else and then
they're like with a big dick or small
deck he's like well a big dick obviously
because you know
you want her to enjoy yourself that's i
heard that so
so he's so i learned that he's actually
a voyeur
he's a viewer and he even said i
remember he even
you got it you've got to hear this
because he says and then he goes on to
say i don't like having sex it's too
much work i'd rather watch
okay i get that no but it's it explains
so much for sure about like it and
even and even weird because it's almost
casts
this voyeuristic aspect to a lot of the
word sexual stuff that goes on
in his vlogs
like he would just be in my house when
we got home to scare me like he was in
my house all the time like so doesn't it
make that i think it makes it more
let's say um
disturbing it's more like um um
invasive yeah when he's getting some
kind of
pleasure from it right which i'm
speculating
but listen to this clip well if he says
it you're not speculating if he says i
like to watch well
what i'm speculating is i don't know if
he was necessarily getting
doing that in your house but listen to
this clip okay
it's kind of interesting would you
everyone have a threesome
yeah sure why not wait really you'll be
down to do one with me
oh with you
wait wait look at that yeah wait wait
look at the graphic
it's like him
would you would you let another man have
sex with your girlfriend in front of you
oh good question i would say no no to
that one
yeah i've seen that porno before but
okay yeah i would say yeah i would say
yeah too totally yeah
yeah yeah are you afraid i'd be afraid i
wouldn't be able to come back from it
i think that is like a very like it's a
very look down upon thing
in the community of having sex
community in the community of
relationships it's a very look
we were laying down on your bed like two
years ago and like i had this random
thought i was like man
i would love to watch my girlfriend get
[ __ ] and you're like oh my god thank
god you said that
i thought it was so weird yeah there's
something about it
yeah it's like because it takes okay
first of all having sex takes a lot of
work
so it takes that out so now you can just
lay there and you're still kind of
having sex
but you're just kind of watching it's
the best i feel like it's so much better
i i love watching i prefer watching them
like like i'm like actually doing it if
the guy is like a big
[ __ ] and then perfect yeah i'd rather
the next day she's like
i don't want my girlfriend to be having
sex with like a lame guy yeah
or a friend a stranger or a friend a
stranger i'm probably stranger yeah
yeah so again not not kink-shaming at
all i mean god bless
but it it's interesting because i was
always like what is the deal with this
guy he doesn't seem
necessarily gay but he's not sexual at
all
you think he's like an asexual no i
don't think he's asexual i think he
wants
he just he likes to watch he's a voyer
which makes everything else is like 10
times more disturbing though like him
asking questions to that 17 year old
about having sex stuff it's like ooh
like why are you taking in the room
and hiding in your bathroom and
listening to you guys have sex
i mean he's very disturbing on so many
levels i feel like he's had some trauma
or something i don't know something
bad maybe happened to him i don't know
he's it's that's sad anyway not to
direct i mean yeah
i i'm not sure i don't sorry if this
seems like i'm unnecessarily dragging
him i just thought that was an
interesting peek into his psyche of
a continuation of the conversation
yeah he's um so funny everything about
david now i'm just like exhausted
thinking about it i'm just like oh my
god it's so much like
we have so much to do here do you want i
have chemical appeal let's just do it
all right
let's give them all about little gnaws
little nausea did you see his new music
video yeah
you're totally fine with that i feel
like you would you can see yourself
atheist or just non
wait you have a problem with his i was
just wondering if he's not i'm not
having him yeah i saw it
and you have no problem with it of
course no problem some things
and even if i like i'm not even like
super religious or anything like that
but there's something so like
whenever something like satanic is
involved like there's this guy that
hairy jay for instance is like santa
i'm saying it wrong like santeria or
something like that where it's like they
sacrifice chickens and
anything sacrificial anything double
like related it just
feels bad and i'm like not religious
because you grow up christian
so you have a little bit of a no but
yeah but like i can have sex with no
guilt i can you know there's so many
things i can do with no guilt like that
you know the christian roots
you're just superstitious or something i
don't know i hate like
i don't listen to like lady gaga or
beyonce because they have a lot of like
illuminati and stuff like that but the
little nozzle was like extremely i don't
know
because he's i think the whole thing is
a parody about how everyone's saying
he's going to help because he's gay
right he's like yeah i'll go to hell and
i'll [ __ ] the devil while i'm down there
i thought it was great i just feel like
i i get really weirded out about like
not necessarily illuminati but
illuminati like does demonic
on earth illuminati does
that's demonic isn't the illuminati just
a secret organization
yeah but it's like making a deal with
the devil jesus that's the devil coming
out that scared me so much i don't think
the devil is part of the illuminati yeah
that's what it is it's all about allah
like no god like ella ella is no god
when they say under my umbrella we're
not singing
if there's no god that means there's no
devil um if there's no
oh i mean i'm not saying i don't believe
in god or is like some higher thing
illuminati is not a satan right can
someone fact check that
well i i don't think the illuminati
conspiracy theories are really a
monolith
uh you know people attribute all kinds
of things to illuminati so
right um so yeah yeah i'm sure there's
lots of people that say
it's religious you loved it i didn't
love it i like it
i'm a fan of his and his music videos
are always like oh like super
creative and and really like the last
one he did the christmas one was like
crazy awesome i loved it
he disavowed his shoes because they have
no collaboration with him but he has
the the devil worshiping star wait he
didn't wait he didn't do those with them
they came out said we have no he but he
has the nike swish on it
i thought it was odd that nobody would
agree to put a drop of blood it was just
a parody is it not a real [ __ ] it's a
real shoe that he's selling but not with
nike he bothers
nike he's going to get some bro you
can't do that
came out today and i was just like okay
thank god because i was like
let me factor yeah
[Music]
so do they need so is that like a if
it's considered
you might be able to get it so they buy
these nikes retail
and then they like customize them but
then that must mean he's not
mass selling them if they're concerned
yeah it sounds like it's like a boutique
like there's like maybe like a few of
them
oh okay 666 remember that then yeah
that's different
but i was like i was like wow nike
allowed to put a drop of blood in the
soul
and that's also just like not sanitary i
know the devil is real though i know
there's like devil [ __ ] on this earth
and not to i won't get into it but i saw
one of my friends like literally saw his
little
one and scared the [ __ ] out of me
because he like changed completely and i
was like oh my god like
literally like listening to this person
you're just like oh my god this person's
like literally something demonic is
happening with them
and i really believe that because this
person was like like a perfect in every
way like so simple that everything
and then the minute like there was like
something a switch i was just like holy
[ __ ] i think there's some demonic [ __ ]
happening here
and it's scary and it's real that scares
me it like makes me sick
talking about him but you brought it up
i know
i think i was like i start talking about
it and i start feeling it my my
opinion on all that is that i'm not a
superstitious person
and i think that the belief in this
satanic and the angelic
and all this is stems i think it has a
lot to do with
with the superstition and ocd
because it's like you go oh i have to
say my hail mary's otherwise i'm gonna
[ __ ]
whatever i don't know how it works but
it's like it's all very ritualistic and
superstitious and
superstition is connected to ocd because
you get this thing of like
i'm gonna something bad is gonna happen
or something's good it's gonna happen if
i do this
i hear demon voices i know they're real
i know demons are real uh
real quick update which is great
in time uh nike is suing them over this
show
oh [ __ ] you don't want to get sued by
nike why would you put satanic and human
blood on a nike product i thought it was
nike i was like what the hell like
that's so messed up
[Music]
mischief as i'm assuming the um
what do you call it the our collective
that ian was talking about that's
gonna end well for them
ian is saying that they made a ju they
made a jesus shoe once upon a time where
they put holy water
oh and was nike cool with that i don't
think
it's like he's like cool with the holy
water with the angels
satan i mean that's racism no but satan
is real
it's racism against demons but who says
satan's evil don't
like like it's propaganda right like
let's say the nazis won then we would
all think like oh the nazis are the good
guys
like who's to say satan's really the bad
guy don't you believe in
he's definitely the bad guy don't you
believe in yang and yang and the
equal powers it's like satan and devil
are
they co-exist together that's like the
balance of nature
right like but they're real like i don't
know what you're trying to argue
well you what what's wrong with satan
like it's like when you look
when you look at the christian god it's
like they say no sex
no drugs no [ __ ] diss its ads like
hell is a [ __ ] popping off party dude
it sounds like satan's like he's like
popping off down there
i'm not someone who's not into fear
convinced there's heaven there's hallie
i'm not something like that all i know
is there's
demons and evil like spirits here on
earth like i've heard them you think
i've
seen them like i've heard i've had
conversations with them like it's really
really scary i've seen people
go to that side like it's been really
really scary and they look like regular
people like whatever but they're
something that like possesses them
that's like truly evil and it's like
really really scary
and i think you just never i was trying
to help i'm just trying to help
i think i was trying to help rationalize
what part
to be less scared of demons and [ __ ] i'm
not scared of them now that i hear them
like i talked to someone about it now
that i hear them i'm not so scared of
them
it's more like recognizing that those
are demon voices and not good voices
because they sound like good voice they
sound like just regular voices in your
head like oh this this
so when they say oh there's a window
like jump out of it like it sounds to me
it sounds like my voice
and it sounds perfectly rational it's
like well that windows open for a reason
like why wouldn't you just jump out of
that right now so it's like those kind
of voices
and recognizing that there are some
demonic things going on that like i
can't really control those are like
some other voices coming to me like
that's are you in therapy about these
things
yeah it's like because i thought i
thought i was schizo i don't you know i
don't know maybe i'm a paranoid
schizophrenic like i don't know like
that's the only thing that voices are
tied to really
and so i hear them like so often and
like you really like
not being able to recognize that they're
demons or just denying that their demons
is like a really scary and dangerous
thing
for me like if i thought that were my
voices i would just go ahead and listen
to them which i have in the past so
um yeah it's pretty scary and it's not
it's a non-religious um he's actually
like he does a lot of like activism for
like gay rights and stuff who are you
talking to about this
um i have a therapist and they tell you
that it's a demon voice
they don't say demons so much but those
are just like these like irrational
it's like intrusive thoughts i get it
okay and
but they're not my thoughts right so
i've had thoughts i know exactly what
you mean
okay so what do you call them intrusive
thoughts is the clinical
expression well i just wanted to make
sure that you weren't talking to a
therapist it was like
don't the demons are real no he's very
not that he's very like
gay you see him every week i zoom i do
zooms with him
every way more sometimes it just depends
how often it happens but um it's more
when it happens because i don't know
like i don't talk to my family i don't
remember talking i don't talk to anyone
about it because it's like really like
scary
no yeah i totally i don't want people to
also think i'm crazy but i just know
like
good i'm just happy you're talking to
someone that's really for sure i think
it's helped like
so much because i've had problem back
when i was like super depressed and
anxious but
i had lots of intrusive thoughts and
they were like
it [ __ ] it really can [ __ ] you up
because you're like in the constant
battle with yourself of like
what do i feel is this me
why did i think that stuff like that
yeah
it's really scary because like i never
had those before like up until like a
few years ago i never had them
and then they kind of went away for a
little bit now they're like back at full
force which is so weird cause i'm like
so happy like i really am so happy in
life so it's like so odd that those
voices come up you're just like what the
heck
um if i was your therapist i would
probably just say because
there's part of you that wants to
sabotage your brain
your good condition right now well it
feels good like i said like denouncing
things in my life like a lot of times if
i felt evil presences i would just keep
going with them and like
being able to like denounce and like
clear myself of any evil around me it
feels really good
so would it help if we got the holy
little naz holy water shoes to wear
i would prefer if i did not see little
knobs i put not interested on tick tock
and they keep showing me his tech talks
and i think that is the illuminati
[ __ ] don't show me dude
tick tock is driving me crazy lately
because i rep
so i get these animal abuse videos on my
home page like literally
like animals dying and being maimed and
like attacking
and i always report it and these are
videos with like lots of views and likes
and i'm like this is disgusting why is
this on the platform and i reported for
animal cruelty and i swear to god they
showed to me more
because i do that because like it's like
i don't want to see it
i i immediately report it for animal
fruity and they keep [ __ ] showing it
to me
i'm going to say something that you
probably won't agree with but i think
it's because you watched viewed and
appreciated little nas x's video
you accepted the devil into you you were
like i think i've been getting these
videos before
you don't think that's the devil animal
abuse you don't think that i got i was
getting these before his video came out
i think you're seeing more because
you've accepted it this is an issue
that's been happening
before little noz video came out because
little noz video just came out
and what do you think about animal bees
don't you think that's the devil what do
you think that is you think that's just
like oh that sucks
well i think there's innate humans are
capable of being cruel of course not
humans
demons well i guess humans can both be
demons and angels at times right
i'm an angel yeah
you're an angel you kind of saved me i
mean ask
james charles if i'm an angel i doubt he
would say that
but if i was a 16 year old boy he might
think i'm an angel you think he doesn't
like you guys of your age
oh he'd like me a lot more if i was
younger
really oh yeah oh i'm okay yeah did you
see how i sent him an arm
armpit pick on after doctor why was that
because he has this phone number he has
a [ __ ] phone number on his instagram
for fans to text him and he goes hi
sisters thanks for calling my thing
i could text you all special promotions
and i might even send you some selfies
and we were like ah and i know that he's
in the armpit hair
wait when did that go oh he asked the
six-year-old kid
or one of these boys to send him a
picture of his armpit oh
i mean that's king shaming maybe oh well
if it's well it's a [ __ ] challenge
yeah
of my armpits i was wondering if maybe
he was fun let's see
what are those numbers for i always see
people be like call me yeah
you text so many people so that's what i
sent him with a heart oh my god you have
no harm pay here what the heck well i no
i wanted to make it look like kind of
a young cube yeah do you have armpit
hair yeah i have armpit hair but i
didn't want him to see it because i want
him to think i was young
um i don't think that looks like young
skin i know
maybe you should have gotten like ian or
something to do it
yeah he definitely he knew how old are
you 35
wow that's crazy i don't know you're so
much older than me
well aren't you like 30 32. oh you're
old as [ __ ]
actually i'm so happy that we're close
in age because usually people on youtube
are like so much younger than me yeah
yeah yeah and i feel like well ela's 32.
so it's like i feel like we're
we're we're contemporary we're contempt
contemporaries
is that what really yeah we're from the
same generation well i feel like all
those like the philip defranco he was
first generation youtuber i feel like
all first gen were you first generation
no no no no really no when did you start
i came
dude phil was like no i was like
well i came i came like pewdiepie was
like
i came like right as monetization
started
oh i was doing youtube four years before
monetization started i was like
that's real [ __ ] as ogs
it's real it's at the party places can
someone please find that for next week
so if you go to a place where they have
the party palaces like the ball pit
isn't that disproven that the mcdonald's
cake
they have them at the places that have
the party party places but those are all
really yeah there was one we saw one
nine dollar so there's
ian you got something to say no oh
okay because on tick tock there's this
whole myth about the nine dollar
uh mcdonald's cake it looks so good but
i saw so many people going
no it's real they're like stop asking
for the cake oh wait really
yeah no i didn't see that okay one other
one other requests
okay what if we do our next costume
episode what if we go ice skating and
we're like nancy kerrigan and tanya
hardy
you wanna actually go ice skating i had
a dream that we did that yeah
which is the way so which is the one
that broke the other girl's flag tanya
harding
hired someone to bust nancy kerrigan so
which one do you want to be i'm gonna be
tiny harding
that's the one who got her knee busted
no no no she's the one you should have
like a
[ __ ] up not a base what is like a baton
you should have a baton
and like and be chasing me that'd be so
fun we could do like interpretive
skating to that
can you believe that she actually did
that what is [ __ ]
psycho she was really pretty margaret
robbie played her in the movie and she
looked gorgeous
just imagine like being like i'm gonna
break your [ __ ]
leg so she can't win i saw the movie
trish is talking about i don't
i don't know if it's super accurate but
in that movie it was depicted more that
it was her like
crazy weirdo husband that didn't yeah oh
she wasn't involved i don't know well
that's how the picture that
i was depicted in the film i don't know
it's not funny how you can have a movie
about your life and then everyone's on
your side again because i was like oh i
kind of go back for tony harding because
she has like an abusive mother and an
abusive husband and you're like oh man i
kind of feel sad for her
it's a good movie you know yeah you know
imagine being so good at something that
someone's like i have to
i just have to break their legs because
i don't have a chance
that's kind of an honor i guess that's
good that i'm not good at anything
because no one's trying to break my legs
no one's coming for me
crazy do you not want to do that okay no
i'm down i mean
drive yourself to get vaccinated you
drove yourself yeah
i can't picture you driving yourself
anywhere what are you talking about
anyways
you think i have a valet
why i'm not bougie at all i can't go
anywhere by myself i get really anxious
like i need somebody like with me
i'm not you kind of well it's like
looking at a mirror
oh god cause i can see you now
i'm looking right at the other hand no
all right so this is a song called
mirror by doesn't turn like yeah yeah
yeah yeah
justin ramen hair justin ramen hair
timberland
all right we've got there we have a lot
to get to before the oddly satisfying so
let's push through
face peeling what the [ __ ] is this
tricia what's with the face feeling
oh my god i looked horrible this weekend
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
tick-tock is just a trout
damn girl you are wild what is this
my skin was peeling but what did you do
to your skin
oh i got a chemical peel which i didn't
know what that meant
and i have such a pick me obsession i
want to pick
i have a p i do have a picking up
session they like burn your skin to peel
off no you see all the scars on my arm
like i
i have such a i have to pick things that
are on me so they literally
put some kind of chemical that burns
your skin off i mean it doesn't seem
right yeah you look like a burn victory
oh my god okay well maybe not honestly
though i made me feel for
like severe burns like [ __ ] it was
really bad it was really itchy and
painful
do you feel it helped your skin no
because i picked it off you're not
supposed to pick it off your damage is
it worse when you like rip off your skin
a little upright so you're supposed to
just wait while your skin withers off
your face yeah
you're supposed to just let it flake off
and fall
5 million views though so someone liked
it oh so it was worth it paid for itself
well now i got my skin's messed up now i
got because if you see up close i'm sure
you can see on these cameras it's like
flaking off
i saw your skin yesterday it looked oh
god okay
trigger warning here's trisha peeling
her this skin off
and i don't know who the this is not
this is
this is oddly terrifying whatever the
opposite
so you're trigger warning to anyone
who's sensitive but apparently five
million people watch this so there you
go apparently no they did
i mean that's just not i don't know who
wants to watch that
i had so much fun doing it oh i wish i
did my whole did it hurt
no it's the best feeling oh my god i
want to do it again that looks so good
don't
don't get another one next week you're
going to end up
oh stop
i hate it i was trying to look like
megan fox today and i feel like i look
like snooky
yeah well because my face is so round oh
here's part two we don't need part two
that's robbing them of the satisfying
okay part two
close your eyes if you're sensitive
bro what are you doing with your life
i like your haircut by the way can i
just say i like your haircut i don't
want it i don't want you no i don't know
i was just trying to be mean no i agree
no i was fast i needed to fire back no i
know i felt a little like
it's fine it's fine no but you made me
feel a little bad and so i wanted to
make you feel bad and that was thank you
but i actually agree that i always look
way fatter when i
cut my hair that's why i wear extensions
but i don't feel but it's fine thank you
for apologizing okay i feel bad about it
it's okay don't feel bad don't feel bad
you don't have anything to say to me
you also called me fat which triggered
that oh oh
well wait what's the point of an apology
if you're watching okay
i was just looking to see if you had
maybe forgot but that's why wait when i
called you fat for the uh
that's what triggered me to call you
back wait the tick tock thing or what i
said you're
i forget what i said well times you said
if i was fat twice in this episode
and you're fat and i was like well
you're fat with that haircut that's why
i said it okay okay wait let's hit some
ground rules
should i not say that um
yeah no it's fine wait should i i'm
sorry
i'm sorry sounded a little aggressive
when you said it but then i was
aggressive and i feel bad i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i feel bad i called
you fat should we hug
no i hate when yes i got insincere
moments
why i thought we we bare we just buried
the fat chit
like the hatchet the fat [ __ ]
i didn't quite we buried the fat [ __ ]
we just squashed the beef instead of
eating it
oh my god wait i'm not being mean i'm
just trying to be funny
can i see another question yeah how does
it feel to have a skinny family because
i have a skinny family too
do you ever feel like a little out of
place
well i always feel out of place with my
family even when you were skinny
yeah oh that's interesting well my
parents were always really annoying when
i was skinny in high school
my mom was always trying to make me feel
like i was anorexic and i needed to eat
more
oh i love that i've never had that
feeling i love that so i was like so
she it was always like you're too scared
it was she was always giving me [ __ ] for
my body
like i was too skinny i needed to eat
more and now obviously every time she
sees me i'm too fat which like yeah
oh interesting so you don't but you
don't feel bad it's so funny because
my family's opposite they literally
never bring up my weight because they
know i'm like triggered by it since i
was like four
but i'm constantly thinking everyone's
thinking about my weight and i'm always
apologizing to them like i know i'm
eating a lot and they're like what are
you like
so i always wondered if you felt that
way or you feel you don't feel anything
um
i know the feeling of what you mean
about how it's like fat and you're
always apologizing
yeah like with mo something i'm gonna
work out tonight i'm going to work i
like he literally doesn't care what i'm
always telling him
to stop giving me [ __ ] for it just
because like she know it doesn't help
right but no she don't not to make her
seem like mean or anything it's she's
always
she's encouraging and she wants me to be
healthy yeah and she wants
that it's not like she's like i i don't
know yeah
but do you i'm healthy you feel but yes
always constantly horrible in front of
your family more so or a lot or doesn't
matter
because i feel totally fine i feel
embarrassed
not because they're skinny i hate to
bring this up so much but i've just been
what's been weighing
on me no pun intended because i'm so i
don't care talking about it
i get lately i've been just really down
on myself i really feel really fat i
probably am the heaviest because i
couldn't fit into any literally i'm
wearing gym shorts i could not get into
anything
and i was just like what is wrong with
me i don't know i just feel a little
depressed
today was not my day because even i put
on i was supposed to wear you know
anyways i supposed to wear this other
outfit and then i was like looking so
ugly i literally had a full
mental breakdown i was like i felt i had
a corset on it wasn't i had this corset
on that like did not fit and i might
just have like
fat rolls hanging over and i was just
like oh my god i mean dude i have i have
that ever
when i get dressed in the morning
there's like shorts that
were like elastic shorts that like
don't fit i just got really triggered
this morning sorry i don't hope that's
not depressing i'm not bringing people
down because like honestly it's just
about it's about me and then i know and
i don't look i honestly swear on my
life like demons come get me if i'm
telling like a lie but like i
literally don't think you're fat at all
but then you always talk about it i'm
like i wonder if anything
i really don't think you're fat at all i
i swear i don't i say it because you do
but i don't think that
really and because you are taller and
all that stuff like that and in person
not to say that you don't i think you
look a lot heavier on camera because in
person you're like a lot smaller
you just don't like i see you do
unflattering things like this so you sit
back
bad you have like bad boys you see you
do that to look stupid but you don't
look like that
you don't look like that you're pushing
yourself but that's why i wondered if
it's like just in your head
it's like a mental thing i don't know
because i've always felt that was fat
kind of but now i feel like i really
have fulfilled the prophecy
should we have do you have dr drew
talking about this i feel like he
specializes in like even just no you're
just going to come
fat shame me and tell your beautiful
angel he'd be like ethan you're fat
trisha you're perfect no but i want to
know the psychology behind it because i
really
haven't ever ordered that pizza we
talked about um
we did arby's has a new crinkle fries
today they just started did somebody say
arby's
i'm hungry though i want to eat arby's
with you like what can i do
i do love eating with somebody that
enjoys food it is fun
i don't know anybody that's different
with you because these all these
[ __ ] losers don't want to eat crinkle
fries and like get
like they don't want to get like bro
just weird about it you know moderation
like let's go
pizza crinkle fries i mean i am working
out tonight
yeah right i am we got our workout
machine got delivered we are going to
work out tonight because i felt so good
remember like three episodes ago i was
like look i've lost i lost like three
pounds and i was feeling so good about
myself
and then i just was like okay [ __ ] it
like yeah the problem i always
i've lately been having i have had
i felt like before i started taking
lexapro the antidepressant oh you're on
that
which by the way i love and like i don't
i love it it's like i hate like the pro
right we've talked about it but for me
it's working right
right and so i don't there's no i don't
want to go off it by any means
but i've had a lot of trouble losing
weight since i
started and so i felt like before the
lexa pro
i could be like okay i need to lose 10
pounds and i was able to do it yeah
but since i started elixir pro about
like a year and a half ago i've been
i've been steadily gaining weight and
every time i try to lose weight it's
like
i'll be really committed for like two
weeks to something and then i don't and
then i get on the scale and i didn't
lose any weight and i just get so
discouraged i say [ __ ] it
yeah i'd never weigh myself that's like
really bad like even the thought of
doing it today i was just like oh my god
no cuz like honestly like
that will trigger me into like another
world it's really weird
but i've been fat my whole life like
literally since i was five people called
me fat so i was just like it to me it's
like
whatever i don't know but the thing is i
am happy now like i am so happy doesn't
get in your way i mean it
like i mean you you
men find you desirable you're successful
you've got everything you want
yeah i think i've just never felt skinny
like what would that feel like you've
been skinny and i'm like oh my god to be
like 130 pounds would be like what does
that feel like
i think it was 130 pounds at like
literally five it's nice because you can
like tie your shoe
you can clean your ass in the shower
it's almost like you went to heaven and
now you came back and tell me about the
experience yeah i'll tell you all about
it
yeah so i can wipe my ass in the shower
obviously but
but it's not like it used to be i don't
know i mean it's got nothing to do with
that okay well that's good but the thing
is like
let's say i got a divorce i mean that's
not happening god forbid whatever but
like
i would probably be like okay if i ever
want to find love again i need to lose
weight okay i'm the opposite whenever i
go through like a breakup i feel like i
get fatter i'm like well i'm fat anyways
who cares
really i feel like that's the classic
guy move though when you have a breakup
it's like hit the gym delete facebook
what do they say they say hit the gym
delete facebook
facebook i don't know why i delete
facebook so that's interesting because i
have talking to eating disorders
probably yeah i'm talking to like eating
disorder therapist and they always tell
me they're like
you're not going to be any happier
because i would say the key to my
happiness if i lose 50 pounds
and like you're not going to be happy or
50 pounds no you're not happy it's just
there's always something
when i was just but there's nothing else
when i was a skinny legend i was there
you know you are you still are a skinny
legend
i don't like that you call yourself that
because you are probably like a mediocre
medium weight like you're probably
average wait bruh
i used to be like 135. okay but you're
what like 220 at like
almost six foot i'm just saying i was a
skinny legend
yeah okay continue i want to hear what
you gotta say it was [ __ ] heaven bro
i'm not gonna
oh you loved it i was just it was like
bliss
yeah it was ecstasy no i'm just i was
just like i'm skinny
everything's great no no you got
problems you got problems it's like
it's the fallacy of people say oh when
you're rich then all you're then you're
happy every day and you have no problems
you still have problems i'm happier rich
well sure
you know what they say they say there's
like a certain amount of money
where it your strength like i think they
say it's like you know something like a
hundred thousand dollars a year
i don't know what what there's a certain
amount of money
that someone can make where you can get
the maximum amount of like
of life improvement from and then
anything else doesn't add
i mean it's scarier to be happier with
money because if you lose it one day
which could happen to anybody then
you're like what
you're gonna be well you gotta go back
to like mcdonald like i mean nothing
against
a stripper probably again you just go
straight to stripping you think you
could strip that like what's the cut-off
age for stripping
um you know what actually i probably
just do like porn or something actually
that's what you already did like rest in
peace but like doesn't diamond just did
porn because he had the name and i was
like you know i'd probably just do that
butterfucko who was that guy what is the
cutoff age for stripping um
i mean there was ones that are in their
40s i mean i'm sure there's some place i
would hire like a
i don't know is there like um granny
strip clubs
um oh business idea
interesting i wonder how they hit that i
wonder if they hit the the pole
should we do a strip club you could have
a real accident though at the pole with
the grannies
oh you got into my shot i like that that
was cool it was cool to see you on all
right hold on we're
listen i love the chit chat wait can we
open up a strip called called fatties
where it's only fat strippers
yeah if you want to go bankrupt i mean i
honestly think there's a whole
tick tock that i'm on of these like guys
just saying how much they want to see
fat girls more in there
yeah okay sure let's let's [ __ ] off
can we try it let's
damn it i'm in mr beast has his burgers
we have our fatty strippers i love that
we're the mr beasts of fat strippers
that could be really good get a reality
show about it
call e god can you imagine people that
would go in there
and then like the food would be like
hella fatty too
oh the food would be bomb people would
come just for the food the butter
noodles your mashed potatoes
just for the food they're like actually
this they're like dude there's a new
michelin star restaurant in ila it's
called
fat strippers and it's we go there for
the food but there's also fat strippers
no it's called
fat fatties fat fatties no just fatties
just fatties yeah fatties naked fatties
just fatties is good we don't even
descriptive about it
fatties is good i like that all right
and now before we get
to oh god it's gonna be a 10 hour
episode whatever who cares people like
it
okay i thought it'd be funny to every
week now i try to explain
a meme to you someone said
that so this is okay fine go ahead go
ahead
no i want to see it people were like oh
trisha pages doesn't get memes but
she likes adam sandler movies she's like
the equivalent of like dad energy
they're saying like you're not it's not
cool like adam sandler anymore like it's
not cool to find him funny that i'm like
this like old dad because
like like obviously like i mean he's not
he's no you know i mean he's no
steven spielberg i mean
let's not put him on a pedestal but
people like kind of like crap on him now
because he has like
i mean his movies are objectively bad
sandy black players
are funny did you see sandy wexler so
good no but like he's made
some of like the worst movies ever like
what was that little nikki
[ __ ] i mean i mean um um
what's the one where he plays his own
twin sister
we should cosplay as them but i'm just
saying jack and jill is widely held to
be one of the ones
i'm not kidding i can quote that movie i
know every single thing about it so you
liked adam sandler but like his movies
he's made some that people i think
people like for nostalgia
i think he's a great actor but if you i
mean if you want to say like he's a
great filmmaker then
yeah i think you have a p i mean let me
follow up the rating here this is why
he'll never be on our show yesterday
you're like that's never going to happen
he's never going to be on our show you
know that right and i was like because
you're saying
i think he's a great actor i love his
acting uncut gems
amazing okay you want to see jack and
jillian on um
it has a 3.3 on imdb
jack that's actually pretty hot raises
undertones which i don't love there's
like an indian kid and like this
hispanic guy that they kind of make
racist
oh yeah dude that was just outrageous
character who fell in love with his
sister oh you know the movie though oh
yeah i watched it of course because i
made a review about it oh you did it
three percent i mean it doesn't get
worse i think people are haters
i think any time i can i think time a
comedian makes a movie where he plays
his
own twin it's a [ __ ] girl
bro that's been done so many times it's
like an eddie murphy thing
it's like a i want to do that that's
it's like a true
okay it'll be bad but i'll watch it jack
and jill's good i think people are just
haters
no that move is [ __ ] objective i
don't like that he puts he has rob
shiner in his movie so many times though
and rob schneider is undeniably not
funny and awesome i agree
although here's the the the critics
consensus
although it features an inexplicably
committed performance from
al pacino
jack and jill is impossible to recommend
on
any level whatsoever i think it's great
that's the consensus of the critics
haters someone gets too popping they
want to try and break it down
yeah that and then like out like i feel
like this movie almost single-handedly
ruined al pacino's legacy
i think it was great like johnny depp
was in the movie it was good
okay whatever listen to jack and jill
[ __ ] analysis show let's just look at
some man and that was the case
all right okay yeah so here's the first
name
okay
okay ready it says i may not be jewish
but the drip
is real okay why am i in
clouds because you're in heaven probably
i thought i'm in israel isn't that the
joke we're in israel
so you do we get like that i mean i get
the the
the was that called the words
i don't get why they use that photo in
heaven because you're dripping
i've used ascended it's a harvard shirt
it's not even a jewish shirt
it may not be jewish but the drip is
real i just don't know we have we we
don't get i like i like the comment i
like the the context it just doesn't
make any sense with my
outfit the location because you're
dripping and what
okay okay next meme
big daddy right is this one big daddy
this one
says trisha making her
i love okay let me read this again
trisha making her i love
moses music video this is you okay
how do you do fellow jews
i like this one because isn't that from
an adam's handler movie i like this one
but what is that from
i think it's from a tv show but do you
get the beer
so this is you saying how do you do with
my fellow jews
well you have to kind of understand the
context of the original meaning okay
the original meme is him trying to act
like he's a like high schooler
how do you do fellow kids yeah so the
meme is he always goes up to kids and
says how do you do fellow kids like he's
trying to pretend
wow so that's you how do you do fellow
jews
okay i like that one i get it yeah yeah
that one's good
okay but again if you didn't explain the
meme i think if you explain to me and
the meme is dead is what i hear
right well you didn't you have to
understand the context of this one
otherwise i don't think
i thought i was in amazon once i got
excited that maybe i'd understand it but
i didn't
um here's another one
this one is pretty deep cut but
i don't get this one my goal in life
is to be uh is to become to make as many
memes as possible to confuse trisha
oh mean i wish it's canceled again
i wish i wish all a very with peace and
love
no idea to be quite frank
i don't understand this meme either hey
well then you tried it
you tried to trick me you don't even
know what the [ __ ] is this stan
dude you haven't you haven't seen the
the bugs
meme no what is the bugs and my god
i missed well it's always very
grammatically awkward
is like part of the joke uh
it's bad this is a deep gun this one
yeah i i
i can't understand oh my god who is this
person put them on blast who made that
meme
i think it was james charles no don't
put james charles on blast or something
he didn't even do
okay this is the final one when trisha
sees this meme
i'm confused
right okay well that's
because this is a meme format okay of
someone
confused so memes are taking one image
and just putting different letters
different words to it yes you guys are
geniuses out there
i'm not smart okay all right so another
caption for that
picture could be me trying to do algebra
that would be funny that's actually
literally oh my god i actually think
that's pretty funny because okay wait
wait
when trish tries to do this there's math
on the thing
i know it's tim literally oh my god
it's so literal that it's funny thank
you like but anyway
if this got by the way this meme got 3
000
points and it was awarded several awards
wow just so you know that this is
non-existent awards
no they're real where they get they get
in the mail they're digital
awards what do you want was that ft
award what is the devil not real all of
a sudden
the demons are real you're
sorry i brought that up where's god's
award i pray you never have demons come
and try and possess you or you sell
yourself to the devil
oh my god what what did i do to deserve
this why did my i didn't i'm not scared
that that's gonna happen
i'm not selling my soul to anybody if
anyone i'll sell my soul what do i sell
myself
nothing comes to mind exactly
not for sale people me neither
i can't be bought um
there's some david dobrik news it's
short though
like for example todd put out an apology
i don't think we talked about this
oh todd the toddster todd
tatarino my man is that from something
too
he just seems like that kind of guy yeah
yeah for sure for sure i get it
todd in case people don't know who todd
smith is because i don't really know
he's this douche
actually i don't know if he's a douche
but he really is i've said todd
brandon david jason those are the four
creepsters of that group like they need
help
dude tough what's good
interns and he's jack though eh i mean
yeah jeff too
damn sup he's the one that had the 16
year old interns with jason
at their house they had like did you see
that video of the 16 year olds they had
that showed up for david and they said
you can work for us and he had them like
clean their kitchen and stuff like that
dude that is and they had like 16 year
old girls at the house and jason's like
these are new interns they're 16. i'm
like
you're 40. you have 16 year olds at your
house cleaning your kitchen bruh
he's 44. at the time no jason not this
guy oh yeah this kid's
like 30 something now pretty jacked
though
i know who's more jack jeff or todd
jeff jeff looks like he's trying to flex
though
jeff looks really skinny i feel bad for
him i feel like he can't work out
anymore
jeff looks like he's like trying to look
casual but he's flexing so [ __ ] hard
well jeff gets more points because he's
he's speaking up and
donating and doing stuff so yeah shout
out to jeff
todd is kind of the worst i'm not going
to lie he's just here's his statement
or did you read a statement um yeah i
did but we can read it
okay todd from todd todd
todd
[Laughter]
toddy boy this is an apology to hannah
and her friends and acknowledgement of
my role in the trauma they went through
and the night and of the end and that
night and the pain i'm reading it from
far away
so part of me
they carried everyday sins i would like
to own up to my mistake
and apologize to those i have hurt with
my insensitivity
i do not condone uh uh actual
essual misconduct of any kind
i'm so stupid i'll just say sexual
misconduct
you can bleep it or something okay
well i don't know with youtube it's like
all of a sudden you're saying the wrong
word and they're like
[ __ ] your whole episode oh i thought you
were like okay
i thought you're trying to get out no
i'm not making jokes i
didn't think that you're trying to be
sensitive towards me or something and i
was like it's fine but i get what you're
saying
i'm sorry for the disgusting comment i
made in that video and
he was the one who said i'm getting
horny i believe when he looked in
right yeah and he did
buy alcohol for himself oh she's yeah
right
that always slides under is that
apparently
allegedly i mean we don't know for sure
but according well i would you
well according to you you saw no i
didn't see him by it i didn't oh you
didn't okay i said jeff i had said
he asked jeff and jeff said i'll go get
it and then we left so okay according to
the
witnesses actually jeff said todd bought
alcohol for himself
and then he changed it and said there
was no call but then he changed it again
and said trisha wasn't there when the
alcohol was brought back so it just
slipped out a lot
but anyways jeff did say todd bought
alcohol first
yeah so and the witnesses said that he
did so i mean we know
there is evidence pointing to todd
coming back with some of that who's
ready to party
all right sorry todd anyway i'm sorry
for all that stuff i'm sorry to have
been a part of a toxic environment that
got in you into this situation
i'm sorry that i was so naive and did
not challenge my own perception
to know what was actually happening in
that room
jump cut to him being like i'm getting
kind of turned on right now
there's no [ __ ] too when they're
like allegedly when they're like nothing
was going on in those rooms every time
anyone's asked
those vlogs are real it's 100 real
nothing scripted it's not i've been a
part of those vlogs it's never like i'm
looking into some fake thing happening
like whoa look at that happening over
there that's the impression
oh you know why i get that impression is
because every time you listen to david
talk up like when you listen
to him talk about for example the seth
thing people were going oh this is fake
and david
go he's wants people to know desperately
that it's all real and it is it is the
way they set up stuff is like 100
yeah they set up scenarios to happen but
like it's not fake what they're setting
up there's always like real [ __ ]
happening that's how he gets reactions
todd continues i was trying to say
uh he says i never left the apartment
until it was time to go
and i did never purchase alcohol despite
jeff
saying jeff said you did
buy alcohol for yourself so maybe you
guys
they did not get their story straight
yeah you guys didn't get your stories
fake come on get out
he did not oh well he says okay he did
never purchase alcohol for anybody that
night
i did hop up to make i
did i feel like the fifth grader who
can't read
i can't see that far otherwise i would
read for you i have like the worst eyes
yeah
just so you guys know it is far away i
did hop up to make a joke for the vlog
what does that mean he hopped up like
oh david eats me what's what's full of
let me think of the room fast
oh i'm turned on right now i hopped up
weird way to write it i was trying to
say something edgy and crude for a laugh
but it was not funny and i'm ashamed of
myself
i am in full support of hannah coming
forward i cannot imagine the way she
feels and i'm so sorry to have been
involved
and i understand that my
inaction was of equally awful
consequence
i was in the apartment and contributed
to the toxic environment that led to sa
i know i need to continue to educate
myself
i sincerely apologize to those i have
hurt
including essay survivors i will
however continue to have 16 year olds
clean my kitchen oh sorry
i got blurry okay yeah
he said uh now i see how my action
added to a culture that allows this to
happen i'm embarrassed that this is what
it took
for me to learn about the effects of my
behavior and action and ignorance
i fully plan on paying the six-year-olds
cleaning my kitchen instead of them
working pro
i'm sorry again i fully plan on learning
from my mistakes and educating myself
through
different resources on essay
it's pretty good apology yeah i mean
i think that's the biggest question mark
about
the alcohol i mean that will never get
answered they're just all back and forth
yeah we'll never get answers i mean the
girl said it was there
it was there was there everyone thought
it was there i mean to me
it's like i i a lot of people say oh
what does it matter that i'll closer but
i mean what to
you know what it doesn't matter it
actually does matter it's supplying
alcohol to minors is a big thing because
like it matters if it's true that dave
was like that's a huge go get it to
liquor these girls up
but guess what even if you didn't buy it
directly for them and there was alcohol
at the house just like a drunk driving
at parties the person during the party
can get sued for the drunk drivers
being killed it was at dom's apartment
right so
but but they could say someone supplied
the alcohol there and then that person's
at fault for supplying minors with
alcohol
no oh yeah it's if i mean if there was
proof that one of these guys got i mean
that's why i left because i was like
this i know for a fact is a really bad
no matter
the outcome of anything happening not
knowing what was gonna happen that night
like it was just
regardless it was just bad it was like
this is bad we're buying miners out like
that's not happening
we're not gonna be here there does seem
to have been a trend of david keeping
the people around him drunk to try to
get entertaining content though so
i mean he's admitted that yeah it fits
the and tana came out with tweets about
saying any guy who flirted or tried to
get at me when i was 18
19 you're disgusting and she said anyone
that's 10 years older than you at that
age that thinks they get you is is it
doesn't and they're just
i mean but it was interesting because
she's older now she's like what 24 not
that much older but you know
25 maybe i mean it's a big difference
from 18 no of course but the fact that
she already sees it because now i'm
seeing this with like younger
influencers like these tic talkers and
stuff like that
it's so disgusting and like i'm glad she
spoke up because like she was such a
part of that like that stuff with jason
and tana like i was just like
watching that back was like so repulsive
she goes it was a fake date and then he
turned it into a real one and i was
confused and why did he try and kiss me
when the cameras were off like it was
so repulsive and disgusting and it just
made me want to puke like jason makes me
like honestly he makes me want to puke i
just i don't know what i'll say about it
and he has yet to say anything and he's
been like a common denominator
interestingly the
one pretty much the only one
now who hasn't made a statement yeah who
is there a band in his youtube channel
like not on not doing the podcast
anymore david has nothing to say
what is jason gonna do or he did a show
he did he's
yeah he's doing stand up i guess huh i
wonder what his acts like
there was nothing nowhere online nothing
about it it's so weird like
so you all heard about the
you all heard about this guy dirty dom
boy that guy's a real
piece of [ __ ] yikes
um yeah it's really gross especially
since he's the oldest and has children
like you you probably should be the
first person to say something because
you're
[ __ ] old like you should know better
does he have a daughter not that it
really matters yet no but it does matter
he has he has a daughter and a son yeah
no
i'm saying what do you mean did you see
that clip which i've been saying this
for
years his daughter he said on the
podcast the 10 year old his daughter i
haven't
you have yep well i don't know if you
want to read that but it was
so disgusting i've been saying this she
lives in a house with
jason and his son and scott let me play
the clip
um ian can you find it you know what
she's talking about it's the one where
his poor daughter is complaining about
living with todd on the path scott and
todd yeah
it's probably on the subreddit i thought
i called it basically yeah but this so
he's gonna pull that we can listen to it
but this video i know you i know you're
not on good terms with gabby hannah
oh yeah i'm not i don't i don't i don't
i don't like gabby can i have my own
issues with her but yeah this is gross
but this clip
genuinely made oh my blood boiled i
i i felt so [ __ ] bad
the [ __ ] that they said and did to gabby
is something that could cause
lifelong trauma like this is so
[ __ ] up and it makes me so
uncomfortable the people who are
watching this
and okay with this this [ __ ] is
so disturbing i will say like i don't
know i won't say anything she said
privately to me but when we did that
when i did the podcast we talked for
like two hours privately off camera and
she told me a lot of this stuff and how
it like affected her like she started
like crying and i wish
i wish i hope she would speak up i mean
i know if she's not comfortable she
wants to get past it but it's like
beyond drama at this point this is like
some really like
humiliating traumatizing things that
like they gave this out to the audience
they said was okay
zayn's never acknowledged heath's never
acknowledged this it's like so gross
like this is a time where i feel like
she
should speak up because she has so much
to say about it i talked to her
privately about it and it's like it's so
gross i wonder what
i remember she tweeted something cryptic
about talking to lawyers or something
yeah but then she's like i didn't sign
any ndas and even if you did like you
can still talk about this i don't know
yeah nda doesn't mean anything at this
point yeah i hope she i hope she does
but anyway it all this clip speaks for
itself because again i wasn't super
familiar with his vlogs
but i have never seen such blatant
and it's not just bowling it's like
really
it's just like nasty nasty like just
like cruel
evil really listen to this [ __ ] really
yeah that's not her makeup that's just
her face oh [ __ ] you're right she ugly
the beauty aisle gaby have you ever been
in there probably not
she's beautiful what turn the camera off
okay i'm still right here
we wanted to do a little secret santa
since we're all going home for the
holidays
and we just wanted to put it on camera
so that we would have it forever i got a
gift
and i got it for gaby oh it's for me and
she's been needing these
and i know how much you love to dance
wait it's something i've needed
you definitely needed it we've all kind
of talked about it are these
diet pills oh my god david that is so
true
exactly and now take four of these and
you can probably dance better it's
amazing what artists can do with
people's faces look what they did to
gabby's
uh it's so lightweight is it a gabby
[ __ ] yeah
she's like she's really like loud voice
really ugly
i mean i wouldn't say
gabby can you hurry up dude you've been
in there for so long
you probably look fine [ __ ] jesus christ
are you a [ __ ] raccoon when gabby's
on her period
i'm so excited to come though that well
yeah i'm always excited to come but i
was so excited to go to target
that i was sitting on my bed literally
just waiting for your attacks i was just
so excited
are you not wearing makeup it's so easy
to tell this is frank this is a exact
replica of gabby's face
so wait till she sees it on someone else
so how often do you exercise
every day every day
so i shouldn't even try right like i
could have an amazing guy and i threw it
away because of
you i could have an amazing guy
that's what got me yeah who's the
amazing guy
i don't even keep a straight face how to
ruin a perfectly good day
hi it's that easy everybody should love
themselves just the way they are
okay so you're probably getting another
shot bro i don't know what you're so
afraid of you've been calling me fat
since
vlog the fact that everyone's like oh
this is such a nice guy
like it's like maybe he's not like the
devil but you know
he was on a [ __ ] anti-bullying tour
is he off that now yeah egg finally got
his ass off that
i mean people just go you're ugly you're
fat i mean that's like the lowest form
of like
but they're not even intellect like that
there's nothing to that like why i feel
like even in middle school kids would be
like okay that's tone it down david
right and she clearly is like why would
you say that that's so mean
it's like it's not like this friendly
banter because they always like to say
we banter with each other but it's
i watched that and i was like i hate him
he is a disgusting
[ __ ] bully and people go oh they
always go
oh everyone's just giving each other a
hard time really what's the joke about
david
right right what's the joke about david
you can't make jokes about david like
david does not like yeah you can't have
anything to say about david
there's no jokes about him well i have
some now well first of all we know he's
a [ __ ] not that there's anything wrong
with that
okay so there's no that's not a
criticism though right so we can't do
that
i mean well he's afraid yeah he has no
he's a bully
he's an [ __ ] definitely a bully yeah
pewdiepie confirmed that too peter was
like i knew it i told you
yeah i did shout out to felix did call
it actually
he actually did i have to give a shout
out to
pewdiepie uh he said something like a
while ago about how david gave him weird
vibes
i mean i've been calling it out too but
yes but pewdiepie well yeah i mean i
give you all
but not no hey listen no no no no hey i
like no like i said
nobody pull it out someone like kim yeah
that was on his radars is
you know obviously you know i know i
know i feel like when people that are
have
credibility can like confirm you know
because i get i get what i look like i
look like a troll that just like comes
with
whatever i hate it though i didn't know
this until h3 live when you said
faze banks said or mac was like or
what's his name mike
mack mike mike he was like well trish
say anything about you i'm like i don't
know
you like i was like with david for so
long i only talk about people i know
even i don't even come hard for like
james like i don't know them like if i
know someone personally
yeah like that i have stuff to say but
like if i i don't know
faze whatever what's his name but i
don't use blanks
that was a triggering podcast just to
listen to your h3 like the little
snippet you played at that i was just
like
yeah it was bad with faze blanks talking
about it with mike
yikes and that's when okay yeah yeah
they're so horrible i was like [ __ ]
these guys
fate guys anyone who knows about faze
banks
i've renamed him phase blanks because
when he thinks
nothing happens because when i think
nothing happens what is that from
also it means he's infertile yeah and
then he's coming
forward right now you look like the
curly right
i don't know will sasso played him in
the movie with the shaved head
can i be a three stooge aren't they
jewish yeah
wow there we go yes we love that can i
be a stooge
you've all you've been a stooge you've
been a student your whole life
i don't know what that means i don't
even know what a stooge is i don't it's
a sucker i think
is it a derogatory term yeah why would
they make a movie like that
because they're numb schools they're
they're idiots
i think but nothing happens can you do
that do it
no pokemon face or is it gonna hurt oh
wait
wait is that wait i forgot about that oh
yeah that's a little bit and then you do
like but just what happens when you do
just one
i don't know you use two hands is the
yeah
thank you dan yeah oh my god i love ya
here do it to me i'm scared i have a
long nails
okay good that's fun
okay all right enough will sasso
hit me up on tinder when i was single
did you find that one clip of jason's
uh oh yeah it's at the top of the dock
you guys
he just wanted to [ __ ] that he didn't
want to date which was we wanted to [ __ ]
you well sasso on tinder who's that
the guy from the three stages yeah
wait i need a picture i need to see a
picture of this guy he'll recognize him
i thought he'd want a date but he just
wanted to
book was see isn't that flattering no
that's not flattering no girl wants to
just oh but it's like
you know i guess for me as a guy if any
time a woman wants to have sex to me
it's a deep deeply flattering experience
it's a little different
but nobody wants to this guy wanted to
[ __ ] you yeah
which usually big guys don't like big
girls it's not a great proposition
he's cute i think he's cute but i don't
like i feel like he's not like brad pitt
you know what i mean it's like hey
let's [ __ ] you're like okay brad pitt's
never wanted to [ __ ] me he's never
come on to me ever this guy that's
[ __ ] awesome
i mean it's disgusting but it's funny
why i mean it's yeah but it was an
honest proposition right
right at least you're trying to be
upfront about it this guy could have
been all over you
sweating i think he's good looking but i
was
not in the market i bet you'd ask me for
weird [ __ ] like
like two fingers in his ass not just one
but two
oh my god like when jay moore was like
i'm gonna give you american express card
i was like is that i'm a hooker
for having sex with me i'm gonna give
you a pre-paid american express card
yeah last time like right before me and
moses became official
no that's that was my last straw i was
like i'm not doing hookups anymore this
is weird
and he's into wrestling so he tried to
like throw me and pin me around it was
crazy
sorry did he have a good could he could
he
throw your weight around or did you have
a weight advantage on him
be good be good
wrestler dolph ziggler he's like this
really like ripped let me get a dolph
ziggler on the screen this is the
opposite of a will sasso
i mean well cesaro is very attractive
too but wait
tell me about dolph ziggler he threw
like like he was able to body slam like
just like
you had sex with this guy this guy's a
hunk yum
no he was so nice too
um twitter he likes big girls he did it
amy schumer
he just straight up dmd was like yo i'm
dolph let's [ __ ] oh i think he commented
on stuff
because i didn't know who he was i think
he commented on stuff and then like a
blue check mark and i was like okay blue
check mark
and you guys just met up we met up yeah
anything never happened no
we hooked up we have but like he didn't
want to date or you didn't want to no he
was so respectful and so nice i messed
up i did like an exposed video because
he you did an exposed video on fourth
doll stick look so bad for him because
he's
literally the nicest guy in the whole
world and like so respectful and so nice
and just like amazing and everything
what did you say about dolphins
we were supposed to go on a date and i
got glam i got full glam and this was i
mean this is so long like five years ago
six years ago
and um he's like hey like i just got
into town because he's here for he's
always working and he was here for like
a wrestlemania or something in l.a and
he's like
i just got into town and i'm just really
tired tonight can we meet up tomorrow
and i lost my [ __ ] i was like this
[ __ ] flaked up i
i don't know i did a video
so wait you did have sex with him at
least once oh yeah uh-huh one time
and then the second time he's like wow
imagine what he's twice
okay good and he's like stay the night
he took me out for drinks like it was
like really nice like he took me out to
go yeah
imagine what he thought that day when he
saw your video he was like
holy [ __ ] this girl is what i know can i
be real i kind of wanted people just to
know i hooked up with him i think that's
maybe why i did it to be like
you know this is like i thought he was
you know so he was able to
toss you around oh my god so strong
cause he's not like super big though
he's like
he deals with big ass dudes all day he's
used to throwing bodies around he's like
i got nothing on this like
yeah it made me feel like i was 20
pounds i was like wow
god i mean i don't want to be graphic
moses here but you know what i mean like
it just
i don't think moses scared he's like he
literally does so here's the clip
you were mentioning that i said we play
um another podcast
classic of jason's
poor ten-year-old daughter expressing
not wanting to live with a bunch of frat
brothers
share your room yeah for now we should
we've done that before no i'm
trying to charlie was not happy about it
she wasn't well she doesn't like zayn's
videos
really so no she she um she was not
happy
he was funny i'm just kidding i've never
seen his videos but
oh even more shade she probably has she
probably has good taste
she was like um she like she like went
she closed the door to the kitchen
she was like can we sit on the couch and
have a talk no
[ __ ] way yeah and i was like yeah
she's like um daddy it's just kind of
like
i like your friends but it's like i'm a
girl
and like you know it's just hard living
with all these boys all the time oh my
god how old is she
she's 10. holy [ __ ] yeah that's
the same she's like you know i'm going
through girl stuff i'm like no you're
not
oh yeah well daddy's about to live on
the [ __ ] streets
you know my friends move in because i
can't afford rent you little [ __ ]
sometimes i do explain money to them and
they have no jason
you're going to try to tell your 10 year
old daughter that you have to live with
[ __ ] 20 year old roommates like that
i've been
saying that it was so weird like nobody
said anything i was like that's so
messed up for that child that i know
so odd that nobody cared that his
ten-year-old daughter was living with
todd
todd and scott and scott's girlfriend
kristen like it was all of them
not normal and then they moved again and
he continued to live with todd and then
zayn moved in zayn would be passed out
drunk on the couch like it was
i was like how is the fact that he would
even joke about like for a ten-year-old
daughter to
muster up the courage to sit down with
her dad in a serious manner and be like
i'm
uncomfortable with this situation is
first of all i think probably
difficult for a young girl to make that
choice right
and then for him not to be receptive to
it yeah and this was when they lived in
the first house he moved again a second
house with
todd and zane and all that and i was
just like ha
it's crazy it's crazy that jason has
said zero like zero things like it's
it's it's so gross like well i listen i
don't know what's the relationship with
these kids i i don't want to kind of
i'm sure that was even harder i don't
wanna i don't want to say you know as
as a as a parent i don't want to say or
make any assumptions but i find that
situation very very very [ __ ] odd
i think there's so many things they
should delete views if they're deleting
youtube videos they should delete the
views podcast because obviously because
the viewing nice
the view ain't good it's also just
showing also why did he re-upload to
facebook
but delete it on youtube oh yeah he's i
i think
probably what's happening is that a
third party is doing the facebook
re-uploads
but what's funny is that like they're
still uploading his videos to facebook
and getting like
mad views and i'm sure it's monetized
it's like facebook is such a is such
a dumpster fire like facebook is
oh it's such a wasteland it's i don't
know how else to describe it
they should i wish myself would come
back and facebook doesn't give a [ __ ] i
mean dude you could prob they're
probably
there's probably i think i have gerd
curd gang is that what i have i can't
like
get something like nasty for food pizza
you want pizza again or what what else
we don't like the same kind of foods we
found this out before our eating contest
you we like very good
what do you want to eat um i don't know
i could eat anything
what's your i don't want pasta that's
for sure you really hate pasta it's so
weird
i don't know if we could be besties if
you don't like pasta i just i
pasta is such a waste of because pasta
is like a really unhealthy food
and so for me if i'm gonna stuff my face
with like
something that's generally that bad for
me i'd way rather eat like hamburger or
french fries or pizza
i really think it's your medication that
may cause you to have gained weight
because you really don't eat like
bad food i never see eating like chips
or cookies like you always kind of eat
like healthy stuff you're
eating like strawberries and like you
know that kind of stuff
i've been hitting ice cream at night oh
that's the worst i used to do ice cream
all the time
started buying ice cream first because
she wanted to gain weight yeah and i'm
eating all of it
and i kind of i you know what i started
to feel like an addict because i never
used to do this but now i do it where i
like
sneak or i sneak bites oh really
like why because because i'm embarrassed
okay
well that's what i was trying to get at
earlier is how you feel around other
people
that's a new thing though really like
the sneaking
the bites because i'm embarrassed like
she'll be on the couch and i'll be like
try to open the freezer real quiet and
be like how interesting
put it back so she doesn't hear i found
that yeah
for sure i think that's a common thing
people do even like subconsciously like
knowing nobody cares in my house i still
do
i'll still go and try and eat something
real quick oh my god it's just
it's just put on tick tock and then call
it a job just like i gotta do this for
my job baby i gotta steal some ice cream
for my job
what's the materialistic eating
i'm not doing that david might be into
it don't give me any more reason to eat
because i'll stop oh yeah
oh david watch that okay there's one
other thing that i wanted to share with
you before we get oddly satisfying two
hours later longest thing ever
i listen we have a lot to talk about
james charles
old tweet he said
he said in 2015 12 year old girls always
managed to make the worst people famous
iron eeler irony alert
is
kettle iron meat kettle what is he
saying iron meat kettle what is the
thing
called hot tea meat hot what is that
thing
you mean the kettle calling the stove
black
i have it what the [ __ ] is that the cat
and the meat
cat meets kettle
someone has now does nobody know dude
what are you doing yeah you
said it oh you're actually saying that
it's like calling the kettle
the kettle calling to something black
it's something meat
something something meat something pop
me cuddle thank you wait
wait wait
[Music]
i've never heard that in my life i guess
ian is smarter than that and what was
the one i was trying to say
the pot calling the kettle black which
is the basis of what pot
calling the kettle block wow we were in
the t round wow
there's no of course this episode is two
hours long we just
i literally just wanted to watch a tweet
and end up being like a 10 minute
conversation
about like we are literally two dumb fat
fatties i mean let's not say dumb i
don't know we're dumb
i'm sorry i thought it was funny i like
the fat
i like the fact that i never had someone
to call fat with me like it's fun i'm
sorry i just thought it was
funny because like i feel like we're
both smart and dumb
at the same time do you know what i mean
i think no i think we're both
skinny and fat at the same time like we
look good
for fat people you don't like smart and
dumb at the same time i don't think i'm
dumb
no i think you're really smart oh but at
the same time you don't understand memes
do you know what you mean okay gen z
over here
and i feel like i'm not i don't feel
like i'm dumb but like sometimes
i can't read and i'm dyslexic oh so you
are kind and like i'm literally
trying to say the caught the cat meets
the pic like we just had that
like we just had a debate about the cat
meets the kettle black mine was more
like my brain is so occupied with other
things that i couldn't remember
you're a genius as einstein says why
see here we go again i'm not even gonna
try to recall this one
he says why
einstein once said
why dan's already googling why
do i remember don't remember things that
i could easily look up
let's do that one dan what was he
looking up back in the day there was no
encyclopedia let's see did i hit it did
i say did i get something did i do
something to memorize something that you
can look up
never memorize something you can look up
albert einstein
the smartest man that ever lived i don't
even remember i'm gonna guess
does it make sense i'm thinking that
that's probably a fake quote
no it's a real person do it do its core
things i don't think anybody go ahead as
well go ahead
go ahead uh the top answer on quora it
seems incredibly unlikely that he did
[ __ ]
see i'm an idiot yeah i agree
you want to do oddly well you're not the
first person to say that he said that
but
he gets mis-attributed quotes yeah
people always misquote einstein they're
like oh einstein was a
christian actually or he was a jew or
einstein actually
support you know same thing with marilyn
monroe it's always like
like fat is beautiful marilyn monroe is
like they always like or people with sex
always quotes about marilyn monroe like
sex is amazing do it as much as you can
maryland like they always yeah
oh like uh as uh abraham lincoln
is famously known as saying death to all
jews
no oh
are you sure how do you know
but it's kind of fun you can just make
up quotes for anybody
right yeah
what's a great quote let's see george
washington once said
these nuts sorry that's so stupid
okay i think i thought we're wrapping it
up are we still going
well we're done we were supposed to do
oddly satisfying and we ran out of time
we are such chatty cats that is true
that's what besties do when you don't
see each other for a week we literally
saw each other also like two days ago
but we didn't really chat
we didn't really spray we are such
chatty cats
bees what kathy's
kathy's chad cathy's chatty kathy's that
dude wingdub
exactly you won't own being a little
dumb
no a little fat yes a little dumb no
you're gonna make me own being dumb yeah
i think that's more you
okay mrs who invented gravity
i heard that somewhere else so i that's
right if we could be like dumb and fast
who
invented gravity i said why don't make
me recall
that why why do we need gravity yeah
good question trisha
whatever i was being funny
definitely that's my comedic energy that
i bring to the show yeah i agree with
that
thanks all right i'm so sorry we didn't
get oddly satisfying but you know what
let's do tomorrow
or i mean not tomorrow no no
okay next week we should just do get
into it yeah yeah
so there's if there's drama that happens
maybe we do two up
like you know if there's no drama we do
but if there's like what if there's
drama what if like something crazy
happens and we need to be honest
i thought what i had planned we were
going to talk about for like 30 minutes
right
and then it ended up being like two
[ __ ] hours that's what happens when
you have the demon
chatty the devil hour came through and
stole it
we don't talk about demons on the show
why are you talking okay i don't like
demons because it upsets you
okay i i'm serious okay
why does it upset you that i don't like
talking about it we're never ending this
show
oh you just want to wrap it up no i mean
no
thank you thank you with peace and love
this is a serious message to everybody
watching
my update right now peace and love pizza
i want ringo starr
peace and love thank you for watching
everybody
we'll see you next week this is the
ending now yes
we cut to do the ending what the hell
can i say i was the original piece in
love did you see that i tweeted peace
and love first
i did see that yeah well you're not the
first person that ever
said it but okay so that was the ending
yes it's over
[Music]
you